okay who knows like fun for like the
first five minutes and then you have
that game that runs on for like way too
[__] long and you're just like can
can this just end skill issue it's not
it's not a skillet it's like you're an
amateur I don't know how to say it yeah
I mean it's it's yeah like I said you
have that game that runs on I mean it
happened in the [__] after dark
stream where we had that game that ran
for like 40 minutes yeah but that was
funny
my mind is melting right now I feel like
only too many numbers and colors what do
I do I feel like I needed to use more
neurons in my brains
I I have yes what's dos that's the
sequel to truth it's so good is that a
joke
this is a [__] post I'm hearing right
now
what are the rules of the game I don't
know I haven't played it I don't know I
was really drunk when I played it it's
basically just like Uno I think except
like the numbers
yeah you get rid of like two cards
I I just remember it looked funny I was
like oh it's blue
you know who knows red and black yeah
yeah complete rules for dos card game is
it could they just say if there's a
difference wait
if Uno means one then dos means two
thank you that's great I did they really
need to make that felt like an
unnecessary sequel I like Bruno was
crushing it yeah we really need another
but oh no attack I liked who knows yeah
yeah that was more that was a bit more
gameplay too okay so here we go like Uno
you have to discard your cards by
matching the cards in the Santa but in
DOS you can only match them by number
right so the numbers need to be matched
first then only the color is noted so
basically it's like a harder version of
Uno that's never going to take off which
is like why do you need a separate game
for that when you can just add
importance
the skill ceiling isn't high enough on
it you know so that's that's only made
it for real you know ranked games that's
a ranks who knows you wouldn't
understand it's it's for people with
intelligence you need a number of IQ to
play doors yeah someone I'm I'm hoping
they didn't put too much effort into
making the rules for that because that
was obviously never going to that was
never going to take I could see why no
one's played this [__] game yeah I
don't know anyone who's played dos again
I played it once I don't remember
playing it though I think I just played
it as Uno who bought the deck
uh I was in uh no you know where it was
it was at the Final Fantasy Cafe and
because next to it they have a board
game Cafe yeah and they had dos there
yeah and I was like what the hell is
this and that was the first time I saw
Final Fantasy game no next to the Final
Fantasy Cafe there's a board game yeah
well the Final Fantasy Cafe you wanna
play boss
you can play it in Final Fantasy 14
actually like triple Triad right but
different I get that reference now
I know he finally gets it after you
finally completed yeah I played the
Final Fantasy game how was it did you
did yeah I liked it yeah I liked it
um I everyone told me I played the worst
one how how did you play the worst yeah
that's the worst one who says it's the
worst a lot of people tell me it's one
of the worst ones probably seven fans
said that [__] they said that well I I
the reason when they tell me why I was
bad I was like yeah I agree with you so
Final Fantasy 8
um is you know has a traditional
turn-based combat similar to the other
final fantasies yeah I assume except
they added the system called Drawing uh
so to get spells you have to like absorb
them from enemies that is the worst part
um and then you're like you're like
let's say your magic power is assigned
to how many of those abilities you have
right so if you only drain like two of
those spells you only get like two so
more often not you just end up sitting
there in fights yeah and just heal
healing your team and just absorbing
yeah like ages right it's [__] but the
game is fun though and I did enjoy the
the story yeah did you skip the
cutscenes you can't
I didn't I liked it I thought it was fun
stories fantastic yeah I got I was like
I feel like I've played so many jlpgs in
like that's caps
I should rephrase that yeah I feel like
I've experienced many jlpgs
because I have that thing where it's
like okay we will
come on Save the Dog final mission kill
God go back in time save 15 people kill
another dog and then come back and then
reset the universe like what the [__]
that's the greatest part of jfpg yeah
and I feel like that's every single jlpg
I've played like that's end up you
always go back in time and kill someone
yeah but that's like saying like every
FPS is just like mission one shoot the
man yeah no no final mission everyone
the difference between just like go to
your village and get some flour for the
bread and then go back in time and then
stab him in the heart yeah that's why
it's epic because it starts it starts
off low and then the expectation builds
yeah but it kind of got like I mean I'm
sure back in the day because this was a
1999 game I think this one yeah this
would have been a mind-blowing
experience but I was like God damn do we
really need to go to space
yeah the answer is where every every
Japanese like fiction yeah every
Japanese piece of fiction media is like
and now we will end with space
how do we finish this Epic Fantasy story
anybody's face
but I enjoyed it uh I thought that you
know um it was decent how long did it
take you to complete
of gameplay 30 hours oh that's pretty
sure that's quite quick that's pretty
what [__] world are you living in
well it's for a jrpg fantasy yeah that's
right actually quite quick I thought you
would be playing for at least 50 hours
did you have any like accelerators or
anything like that or yeah the game is
times three built in okay that makes
sense times three by all is it always
times three but during the you know when
you're drawing these abilities yeah yeah
because when I played eight the first
time I took at least 50 hours holy [__]
the walking speed around the Overworld
on times three was just was like okay
this is nice and then I turned it off I
was like this is unbearable
it's not like like [__] honkai fans
feel when they finally discovered
there's a normal speed
why is it in slo-mo
um it's like in Pokemon when you learn
how to run finally it's just like oh my
God finally at all speeds I don't know
if this is like strictly like this
game's problem but another a thing that
I I and I think I think a lot of video
games do this in general
they assume you have played video games
right yeah so like when you go on a
first person shooter they just assume
you have played other first person
shooters yeah right like there's just
things that they don't tell you and they
just assume you're like oh you know what
you're doing yeah I want to point the
gun and shoot yeah you know you know
that the if this Mass buttons to click
we don't need to tell you the other
Mouse buttons to aim you know that same
with the triggers like you just like
there's a bunch of things they just
think you know and I realized that Final
Fantasy just assumes you know how to do
RPG stuff and I got in this menu and I
was like what the [__] is this they
start telling you like press this do
this and I'm like this is too much stop
stop so the first five hours of the game
I was like I don't know what I'm doing I
just I just did not understand the menus
because it's too much yeah it's like you
got to assign this character this and
then uh but he listen to jrpgs yeah yeah
designing summons they're like yeah and
then like they're like oh assign the
summons then what a summons you assign
uh allow them to pick from these
abilities these abilities let them do
this but are you gonna pick three
abilities and then they have uh
abilities that are tied to their
offensive defense and uh I guess other
offensive but it's not their other but
they have a completely other stat for
like offensive stuff as well and you're
like what the [__] is this what happened
what the hell and people were like uh
that seems pretty standard to me yeah
yeah and then I just luckily there was
an auto optimize button so I would just
click that and I was like it's good
enough we're like no what are you doing
and I was like all right listen I didn't
I don't get drunk you still completed
the game which is the importance I'm
exactly yeah everyone acts like jrpgs
are impossible if you don't do like the
perfect one frame optimization and it's
like dude these games are beaten by like
five-year-olds yeah it's not I want an
auto button for every jrpg honestly yeah
yeah I think if you have like I I think
I Final Fantasy Android and and towards
the end of it you know the menuing kind
of got a little more fun as I got really
into it yeah but that was like I'm
talking like 15 hours in yeah that's and
I'm halfway through the goddamn game
before I started getting like oh this is
kind of fun to Theory crafting kind of
thing but I think it's just too much
it's like I think I spent 40 of my game
time in a menu yeah because I think it's
just too much for me like I've had that
kind of those kinds of moments where I'm
like are you you know there's there's
something magical about figuring out
like a mechanics and I try this
combination yeah this fight I hit him
with this yeah yeah yeah because I'm
that type of guy who you know in the
first like sometimes you know jrpgs
their tutorials are like last eight
hours long yeah yeah like you're still
going to introduced something eight
hours into the gameplay
um and I'm that [__] who reads
something other than just like it's gone
yeah it's gone it's gone like I'm like
uh so this does this and I like see the
words and I process it
but then it doesn't like stick with me
yeah I do that too I'm that kind of guy
who needs to see like cause and effects
yeah I need to try it out I need to like
put the stability on yeah hit someone
with it be like no yeah the amount of
times like I've been like streaming like
you know recently of course like honkai
I've gotten a character and I'm like let
me let me read what the skill does and
chat tells me what the skill does and I
I I'm like oh I get it I don't get it
I'll read it I'll read it and I'll be
like can someone tell me in simpler
English they're like it's good or it's
bad I'm like thanks guys equip it or
don't it quick yeah and then I go into
battle and then sometimes I die and I'm
like oh okay I get it now you know and
one thing I've I've I've always hated
about some jrpgs and and I guess this is
the problem is that sometimes like like
you know I was complaining to give me
too much information yeah I'm like what
the [__] is this and then the bane of my
existence when you're reading an ability
and you're like will cause a slight
increase to to Critical Strike chance
and you're like can you give me a number
like like because slight could be from
anywhere between 0.1 to like 10. yeah
and and one one percent attempt is a
massive difference here we're like this
is the difference between this just
being a random once in a [__] Blue
Moon One play run or what one
playthrough chance it'll happen or this
will happen fairly often in battle and
I'm like yeah it's pissing me off that
it doesn't it'll literally it'll
literally tell me the [__] length of
every character when I I choose them and
that every hair follicle amount they
have left but it won't tell me the
goddamn [__] abilities like actual
information that I need I think it's
because no one's expecting people to use
that item as like a crutch yeah for
their gameplay you know they're just
like oh it's just like an added bonus
right right if it happens cool if it
doesn't hey it's all right I've got
these other [__] you know yeah like uh
what game was I playing or it was like
oh um if I used
there's a game like if I use like oh it
was like ring fit yeah ring fit right I
was playing ring fit and it was like if
you use a red ability after I unlock
this thing on the skill tree it's like
there's a chance it'll cause another
free attack and I was like oh chance
what does that mean what would you
consider a chance to be
there's a turn-based combat and they
said yeah if you use a fire ability and
you and you have this point unlocked you
have a chance to get another one maybe
10 yeah what would you I didn't know
what number to magically pull out my ass
yeah to like decide what this would be I
thought 10 or 20 because that's what a
chance sounds like to yeah yeah sounds
like listen now don't get your hopes up
but it'll happen
you know and so I was like okay cool I
won the whole [__] game and I didn't
get one and I was like see that see that
that's [__] because I went through the
skill tree to get that chance because I
read it and I thought oh that sounds
strong yeah like an extra turn that's
great yeah and then it must have been
like one percent
really [__] unlucky yeah yeah either
way I wish that like they gave me a
number and it's like the one time the
one time I want a number they don't give
me the [__] number but wouldn't it
have pissed you off more if you saw that
number and it was like instead of chance
if it said like you have a one percent
no I'd love that because I can be like
that's absolute garbage I can
immediately not even entertain right I
can just go straight past it yeah
um and there was also I the one thing I
always enjoyed
um because I did play some jrpgs or RPGs
when I was a kid and I always enjoyed
those like weird little like fun little
Easter eggs you could run into or you're
like go right here and then do this
thing and you'll find this crazy boss
and you're like oh that's cool yeah um
yeah and they had I've had plenty of
those it's fun yeah it's interesting
when you mention like the kind of like
the kind of assumptions when it comes to
like approaching a video game or just a
video game genre I remember seeing like
a pretty interesting video I like about
this yeah the ones where I can't
remember the name of the video but it
was the one where the guy got his wife
your girlfriend wife I'm not sure which
one to who has zero basically zero
experience with video games and got it
to play a bunch of video games and see
how intuitive like the video game was
for this person who has zero experience
no they're not very yeah yeah yeah
exactly
and you realize how ingrained the the
language of video games are in your mind
right and make it makes me think about
just how ingrained every kind of piece
of UI or computer is like you know when
you're teaching your grandma to be like
how does this not make sense if you get
an error message it means this and you
have to click this uh and just like the
simplest thing that you've kind of just
internalized
um that you take for granted that might
if you have zero experience with it uh
you would know because we've had a very
lucky kind of like journey to be able to
see video games experience video games
at their simplest and be able to like I
guess grow up with it and and slowly
learn the language a little bit by
little bit yeah um because I remember
the first time I think I experienced
this was like playing a Souls like a
soulsborne game and just not knowing oh
yeah what the rules are at all I'm like
where are the tutorials where is the
things that tells me what the mechanics
are where to do what to do and I thought
you know first time I played I was like
this is [__] but it's not telling me
anything how can I how how am I supposed
to play the game but you know when
you've realized that sense of discovery
of discovering Mechanics for yourself
and discovering the little things that
maybe the devs have put in there that
weren't in a tutorial stage that to me
is way [__] better than giving me
eight hours of menus and tutorial
screens to be like you can do this for
this and you can do that for that and
I'm not going to internalize that anyway
and I'm like I'm sure I'm sure I'll
figure it out somewhere along the line
yeah yeah right yeah it just sucks I
felt like I figured it out halfway
through the game I was like okay I think
I get it but that's to me that's that's
when I've normally figured out that's
normally when I've had that magic moment
I that's I think that's why it always
takes me like so long to get into a new
video game is because I've I I really
start figuring things out around like
eight to fifteen hours through my
gameplay yeah
yeah yeah so because I'm a story gamer
so
I'm a story gamer so I never go in for
the mechanic so I'm like what what are
these [__] [__] things in the way
of my story I don't give a [__] about
that just give me like the auto thing
and then halfway through Maybe by
normally it's like by complete chance
something cool happens that I don't plan
for I I've done do unintentionally I'm
like yo what what the [__] was that that
was actually really cool actually and
then that's when I that's when a game
goes from a good game to a game like I
become obsessed with yeah um if it can
just sell me on the mechanics like sure
accidentally as well